what everybody we are from phenotype and  today we have come up with a new way of  table tennis trying old table tools okay  so the rules are the same as in table  tennis but with two exceptions you're  not allowed to hit the ball back twice  to the same player and first serve the  left second serve to the right  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  well as always of the one but we had a  lot of fun yes we did remember subscribe  and watch our previous videos that until  next time